13 votos a favor voto en contra una
abstención
con un claro evento de Rusia el consejo
de seguridad de la ONU fracasa en su
intento de ampliar el acceso humanitario
al norte de Siria la extensión de nueve
meses del acuerdo Deja de ser una
esperanza para los millones de
habitantes de la región a Merced de la
ayuda internacional
lo que el mundo acaba de presenciar es
un acto de crueldad absoluta la mayoría
de este consejo se unió para ampliar
esta ayuda humanitaria con el fin de
salvar vidas pero un estado Que es
miembro permanente bloqueo esta
resolución de compromiso
los 15 miembros del Consejo de Seguridad
llevaban días intentando llegar a un
compromiso para ampliar el acuerdo que
desde 2014 ha permitido la entrega de
alimentos agua y medicinas en el noreste
de Siria pero Damasco considera las
entregas de ayuda como una violación a
su soberanía
quienes han hablado hoy de vida y muerte
deben levantar sus sanciones inhumanas
contra los sirios en lugar de llorar por
la difícil situación de los sirios
Moscú Aliado de Damasco Lleva años
cuestionando el acuerdo ya que el paso
fronterizo de babal Java se utiliza
actualmente sin la aprobación del
gobierno sirio
las principales características del
texto son un desprecio total por los
intereses del pueblo sirio y pretende
provocar a Rusia para que recurra a su
veto
la última medida ha puesto en entredicho
el futuro del corredor de ayuda que no
podrá reanudar sus operaciones hasta que
la ONU le de luz verde de nuevo la
necesidad de la ayuda humanitaria sea
multiplicado desde el terremoto de
febrero después de la catástrofe más de
3700 camiones de la ONU con ayuda han
pasado por los tres puestos de control
disponibles